carol baskin
i'm carol bastian
does the name joseph maldonado passage
mean anything to you he is a psychopath
who wishes me dead we've been in an
ongoing dispute oh it's joe
i'm sorry i understand this must be very
hard for you
oh no sorry i'm allergic to cats
[Music]
i really feel like i was put on this
earth to rescue cats
welcome to
the best exotic animal show in these
united states this is who we've been
after
documented animal abuser joe exotic
we're coming for you baby i've had to
fight for everything i got i didn't even
know you had a husband almost 12 years
i come from a home
that didn't feel like a sanctuary when
there are no more animals in cages then
there will be no more need for us to
rescue them someone's got to kill that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you have no idea what i'm willing to do
for my animals i got a job for you don't
let me be misunderstood what kind of
firearms you're looking for something
that will stop a hitman in his tracks
[Music]
so it's war it's war
we're gonna make a family at this park
no one can say a damn thing about it
here's to the unwanted animal
it ain't just about the cats spoiler
alert
so how many people are going to see this
little documentary of yours
you want to blow some [ __ ] up he shot me
bang bang bang three times he shot you
technically it was a blow-up doll of me
we're ready to roll
this is a show i can sell this america
he's gonna love you
i will never stop
if you've got any dirt on this woman i
want to hear about it he has no idea
what i've been through in my life is
this awesome or ridiculous individually
we are a whimpered
but together we are a roar
you see me now
i always thought cat people were a
little weird
[Music]
you